a question that some of you might have
asked or maybe haven't asked is where do
we get our hydrogen from
because molecular hydrogen if it was
just in the air
it is lighter than the other things that
make up the air so it would just float
to the top of the atmosphere so how
would we get it well
this reaction right over here is
actually one of the most cost effective
ways
of getting molecular hydrogen which you
can see
right over here on the right what you do
at a very high temperature or what i
would consider a high temperature
roughly between
700 and 1000 degrees celsius you get
some
methane gas in the presence of water and
of course
water at that temperature is going to be
a gas we're talking about steam
and then they will react to produce
carbon monoxide
and molecular hydrogen
now something might be feeling a little
off when i wrote this reaction
like this so pause this video and think
about what
is off here and i'll give you a little
bit of a hint think about
what are we inputting what are the atoms
and the number of atoms that we are
inputting into the reaction
and then what are the number and the
types of atoms that we are
outputting for example we have one
carbon that we are inputting between the
methane and the water
and we have one carbon that we are
getting out on the other side
think about that for the oxygen and the
hydrogens and see
whether it all makes sense all right
now let's work through this together and
actually to help us visualize
instead of just writing it in this form
i'm also going to try to visualize the
various molecules
so this right over here is a methane
molecule you have one carbon
that is bonded to four hydrogens you can
see that up there ch4
ch4 here we have a water molecule you
have an
oxygen that is bonded to two hydrogens
and then they react you get a carbon
monoxide molecule at least how i've
visualized it so you have a carbon and
an oxygen
and then i draw the molecular hydrogen
molecular hydrogen has
two hydrogens bonded to each other and
that is what i have depicted here
now based on the hint i gave you before
i asked you to pause the video
you would notice that we have a carbon
on the input side
you have it right there and we have one
carbon on the output side so that seems
to obey conservation of mass now what
about
for the oxygens well we have
one oxygen between the methane and the
water that we're inputting into the
reaction and we have it drawn right over
here
and then we have one oxygen that we are
outputting
on the output side of our reaction right
over here
now what about the hydrogens well on the
left side of our reaction right over
here we have
four hydrogens plus another two or six
hydrogens
you can also count them here one two
three four
five six hydrogens well on the right
hand side we only have two hydrogens
and they're in one hydrogen molecule so
what happened to the other four
hydrogens they can't just
disappear we have to have conservation
of mass
so we need to have another four
hydrogens on the right hand side of this
equation
well how can we have another four
hydrogens well that's if we have
two more molecules of hydrogen so that's
one
and then that is two so instead of just
having
one molecule of molecular hydrogen that
has
two hydrogen atoms in it we now have
three so to
balance this chemical equation all we
have to do is say okay we don't just
have
one molecule of hydrogen here we have
three molecules of hydrogen and what i
have just done
is balance the chemical equation it's
just making sure that we have a
conservation of mass
that we don't have constituent atoms on
the left-hand side that somehow
disappear on the right-hand side or
we don't have constituent atoms that
somehow appear on the right-hand side
without ever being input
into the reaction